I was going down a path where it's like
I was doing too many crazy things and my
age especially and eventually I was
bound to mess up and I'm glad I I'm kind
of glad it happened because they put me
in check yeah
all right so you're totally sober yeah
fully I just want to know kind of how
you're doing with quarantine and with
just what's going on in the world right
now how how are you I'm doing fine all
the boys are kind of just staying inside
filming content the quarantine
definitely has tested our creative
ability quarantine has definitely
decided who the real creators of of
social media are so you've been putting
out a lot of content I think where are
you
like who exactly are you with are you
with all the this way guys kind of
walked me through yeah this way boys
we just recruited a whole bunch of new
sway boys because some of the sway guys
the oh geez took a hiatus from sway Josh
and Geney but we retreated we recruited
a whole new group and ready to kill it
all of the boys now like the new group
had the same vision overall we all want
to do YouTube with old group like not
everybody was on the same path like
again like James a rock star Josh's more
entrepreneurial
Anthony's video games kids video games
like everyone just had like a different
path but now everybody like with the new
group wants to do YouTube pursue that
why YouTube because its word real
content creation goes and if you're
starting on a platform like tic toc with
short form content like 15 a 60-second
short form content you're kind of
setting yourself up to go on to do a
bigger and better thing okay and YouTube
is it's kind of where everybody takes
off it's kind of like the end goal yeah
well not the end goal but like the last
step into the end goal
[Music]
what is the end goal for me I want to
create my own show I'm working on my I'm
working really hard on my party animal
brand to expand that and everything it's
doing great with with everybody else
it's like you can go anywhere it's it's
like acting real estate modeling like
you can literally do anything I I
personally want to do I want to sell my
own show I want to do reality shows I
want to eventually work on long-term
collaborations with with big youtubers
like like my favorite YouTube youtuber
personally is like lowball like the nelq
boys Danny Duncan like that style of
YouTube is definitely like my genre
which way I want to go but that's like
where this way comes into the factor
we're trying to meet in the middle of
its ways like the only tick doctors that
have a personality good enough to be on
YouTube in my opinion and I feel a lot
of the internet thinks that as well we
want to we want to cause intent on
YouTube we want to shop at youtubers
yeah walk me through who all is in sway
now the new rebrand yeah yeah so there's
no aback myself
Griffin Johnson Blake gray Riggs well
before everything shut down we actually
went to the hype house and we did it
feel like get to know you type questions
with a lot of those people so I kind of
want to do the same with you what first
inspired you to get on Tik Tok so I saw
there was this tour called the lights
out tour and it was like basically
Jayden Hosler Josh Richards Chase Hudson
like that that original eboydee nice all
these kids and myself coming from
musically I I always I promised myself
I'm like I'm never hit the tick-tock
like heck no like I'm a youtuber like no
not about this but I saw their
engagement and in like what they were
doing on the platform and I was like I
can do this
I can do some dances I can do I can do
lip-syncing I just I came up from that
originally on musically and I hopped on
because of them because they started
coming over in my house and they told me
to do it just like okay fine when I when
I talk to chase little honey can you
talked a lot about being bullied growing
up and how tick-tock has really helped
him was that at all the case for you and
even if not like honey feel like tick
tock has helped you kind of figure out
who you are I've been bullied from
elementary school all the way into high
school I've always I was always just
like different like I was weird weird
good growing up and tick tock isn't as
Prince musically used to be and it was
actually really cringe and I understand
why people in high school were bullying
me for it cuz the stuff I was turned on
there was it's pretty gross but honestly
I was never bothered by bullying I mean
like I was like I've been criticizing my
whole life growing up and and even now
like when I get hate it just it doesn't
bother me because I'm just like I've
been criticized my whole life I'm like
why do I care what these people think of
that if you like me like me if you not
you know I feel like people are gonna be
surprised to hear that yeah how do you
see Emily you're not affected by it but
how do you handle it or do you not even
really think about it I've always
handled it by ignoring like like I don't
I don't respond to any hate like when I
when I see it I mean if it's like a
flood a flooded amount of hate I'll like
put my opinion in my perspective on
everything out there and if you
understand what I'm saying you do if you
if you think I'm still like that piece
of and then go for it like I'm just I
never try to offend someone I always
like breach this - I'm not a
social-media influencer on a social
media content creator
I never condone any things that I do out
there on social media and my intentions
are never to offend anyone
yeah it's just I put out content for
entertainment purposes only
a little more than because you do want
to really make your YouTube presence the
biggest part it sounds like of the Bryce
Hall brand and you want to do reality
shows do you want to star in a reality
show or you want to produce a reality
show
is there a reality show about sway la in
the works there is a potential sway la
reality show in the works but I want
yeah I want I don't want I want to be
like the main focus of the reality show
I don't I don't want to sell like a show
with a group and everything I want I
want me to be like the executive
producer and also be the main focus what
would what would we learn about you in
this show what kind of what parts of
your lives of your life just my
perspective on everything I've been
doing social media for seven years and I
feel like now everyone's starting to
realize that I I don't care I'm very
sarcastic sometimes like and and like
when people hate on me like I want I
want people to see what I go through
when I get like that clash of hate and
how I deal with it because it would help
like a lot of social media influencers I
feel like that are getting hate
especially ones that don't deserve it
what this air on YouTube are you
actually looking for like a paid for
streaming service or network cable I
feel like you would start out on YouTube
and then eventually sell it to like a a
bigger network okay I like that you have
all this planned out are you are you
like a forward thinker are you someone
who's always thinking about the future
yeah yeah for sure
[Music]
how'd you learn the date bad way
tick-tock yeah awesome you just like
started watching videos and teaching
yourself yeah myself is just like if you
watched my first dance video to my most
recent I personally don't think that I'm
like a good dancer but I don't know like
a lot of people think I am a good dancer
but I just kind of like troll the dances
like I make fun of them like I don't
actually try well changing subjects just
a little bit you penned this really
heartfelt essay after your arrest
earlier this year and you talked about
the shame that you felt and the guilt
that you felt I'm just curious what have
you learned about about yourself then
what changes have you made personally
well I've been practicing sobriety
that's a huge factor in in moving
forward like practicing with mental
health and like overall physical health
my mind feels clear I came to a huge
realization when I was in that cell that
I ended up like my father and that is
one thing that I promised myself that I
would never be like my father was never
there for me growing up and 20 years
like I practically literally promised
myself the best 20 years that I would
never do that and then I was literally
met so realizing like obviously wasn't
for the same reasons that he was in
there for but like I felt like him you
know I practically I promised myself I
wouldn't you said that you're practicing
sobriety like did you feel like you had
a problem or was that just like a
personal decision as you were as you are
continuing to self-reflect
I wouldn't say a problem but it was it
was more it was more of a personal
reflect like I want to do go sober just
for physical reasons like physical body
image reasons and also like I was going
down a path or it's like I was doing too
many crazy things um at my age
especially and eventually I was bound to
mess up and I'm glad I I'm kind of glad
it happened because they put me in check
see you're totally sober yeah fully wow
that's amazing congratulations that's
huge thank you you did talk about in
that essay your dad and not wanting to
follow in his footsteps do you guys have
a relationship at all no you tried to
reach out to me a few times that I just
kind of ignore him after after the tick
tock success after I started blowing up
on social media back in 2014-2015 I'm
sorry to hear that
that's okay thank you
you are only twenty you turn twenty-one
when's your birthday August 14th August
14th so what will you do to celebrate
the big two one I will be drinking you
will drink on the 21st birthday look I
will be drinking just not as often as it
was like I won't like I won't be doing
it as frequently yeah like it's only
special occasions now like like very
very special occasions okay how do you
feel like you must feel great
Oh amazing yeah 839 in every single day
like waking up without a hangover waking
up like just mine clarity like just
everything I feel great
I feel like you use your platform for
good as much as you can I saw that you
who donated proceeds to black lives
matter from your last merch yeah why was
that important to you and we'll start
with why was that important to you I
mean I just I felt like even in my seven
years of doing social media like not
giving back like I I need I felt like I
needed to give back especially to a
cause like this it is it is a huge
problem racism is a huge problem and I
wanted people to know like I wanted to
encourage other social media influencers
with a platform to like you guys have
money like to give do it you know yeah
people follow up and big influencers
footsteps in that one I want people to
catch on and be like yo guys use your
platform by gay yeah do you feel
pressure to be a good role model no that
goes along with me being a social media
content creator like I don't encourage
everybody to do a hundred percent of the
things that I do at all times but it's
like I am a good person at the end of
the day yeah well when you think about
there are younger kids that do look up
to you and do want to emulate you or
they think that you're just like the
coolest person in the frickin world how
do you handle that I think I'm going to
put out way more than hey don't do what
I do like disclaimers yeah disclaimers
at the beginning of every video that I
have out there
do you ever see sway la and the hype
house combining and creating one big
house would you ever be up for that I
wouldn't say we would combine because
there's so many members in the hype
house but collaborations together on
different products different social
media platform collabs yeah definitely
100% there were a lot of exits from the
hype house but everyone still seems for
the most part friendly if you're like
Charlie and Dixie left but then Daisy
also left and that wasn't maybe as
friendly
what did you make of all of them leaving
I mean it's inevitable for groups like
of that size to to split I mean as of
right now they're doing great super
proud of them
there is no contracts binding them
together there's no real like there's no
formula there's no that there's nothing
like binding them are bonding them
together contractually so I mean like I
don't know what the future is they're
doing amazing now like they're doing
great whatever they're doing
Thomas is handling that perfectly I
guess I'm super proud of all of them I
don't know like what the beef was about
all that I don't know there's like some
sketchy stuff going on I don't know I
don't I just feel like I shouldn't speak
on something yeah yeah no that's really
fair what's been the best part of Fame
for you and finding it on the Internet
what's what I love I love creating
content I love making videos it's always
what I've been I've been doing this
since I was 14 years old and bout to be
21 like I just love what what about the
hardest part I feel like is you animals
sometimes I just like and being watched
and like any little thing that I do or
say could be portrayed in a negative way
yeah that sucks
and and and especially like even even
like with the zoo animal thing like our
addresses leak there's people
like looking through our windows like
knocking on our doors I get it love love
my fans love like all the support that
everyone gives them like I would love to
take pictures like outside like at the
mall like anywhere in public but our
house it's kind of excessive yeah Gary I
mean do you at that point consider
moving or hiring six oh we are moving
moving okay just because that's I mean
that's kind of terrifying
huh I won't ask how the address got out
but our hopefully see you you did say
that this time is also like helping to
separate who the real content creators
are so how are you staying creative
during this time well sobriety is a huge
help
my mind is flowing like non-stop I think
of YouTube video ideas like I like doing
stuff that youtubers don't do like I
like doing stuff that's just completely
random out of the ordinary nobody would
expect
[Music]
is there anything that you want to say
to your fans whether it be like a
message of hope or something that you
want them to know about you um I just
again want to highlight the fact that
hey guys if you guys are watching this
don't do what I do I have a social media
content creator I'm here for
entertainment purposes only I don't
condone any of the things that I do know
some of you guys next vlog peace out
[Music]